this is the M2 iPad Pro and while it's
the best iPad you can get right now I'm
actually very disappointed with it and
it's not something that this thing does
wrong it's actually something that's
coming in the future which is the M3
iPad Pro and in this video I'm going to
explain why I'm disappointed with this
iPad Pro compared to the previous one
and I'll get into why the M3 iPad Pro is
gonna blow the socks off of this one and
why it's gonna blow your mind there are
so many leaks that are coming together
to create the ultimate iPad Pro and
you've got to hear about it but first
I've got to talk about the problems with
this one the main one is the price yes
you can get it right now for about 750
to 760 dollars a little bit of a
discount compared to the 800 MSRP
however you can get the M1 iPad Pro for
about
560 dollars on Amazon on renewed which
is an excellent deal now you're gonna
say of course this is the M2 iPad Pro
it's so much better right well no this
is the most disappointing iPad Pro
update we've ever had on any iPad ever
sure it has Wi-Fi 6E but honestly it's
kind of a gimmick right now it's not
really worth it to get Wi-Fi 6E because
you have to have the router and then all
of a sudden the range isn't that well so
it automatically kicks down to five
gigahertz anyway yes we have the new
Apple pencil hover feature which could
be cool for artists but people who don't
draw every day it's not going to be a
big deal it's just a nice little bonus
and other than that there's really
nothing else that you're getting except
for the m to Chip and to be honest the
M1 was already overkill for the apps
that you get on the IOS app store so in
my personal opinion getting the M2 Chip
versus the M1 isn't that big of a deal
now yes we did get some advantages like
Pro res editing becoming a lot faster
because of the media engines packed into
the M2 Chip and yes the FPS did improve
for the highest end games out there like
yenshin impact but honestly guys I would
rather recommend that you spend less
money get the M1 model if you need to
buy something right now however if you
don't then you should definitely wait
for the M3 iPad Pro because it is gonna
be insane so let's get into the leaks
but before I do that I've got to talk
about what's making this iPad Pro float
the Infiniti Pro iPad stand from our
partner Banks it's packed with strong
magnets to mount your iPad allowing
hands-free use in either landscape or
portrait mode and the stable anti-skid
base rotates
360 degrees and it even supports drawing
mode as well so check it out using the
link below now getting into the leaks
for the M3 iPad Pro one of the main
reasons why I'm so disappointed with
this M2 model is because this is not
what we were supposed to get this is a
stop Gap product basically just a chip
swap with an additional feature and some
extra Wireless specs that's it this is a
complete stop Gap and I'll explain to
you why check this out in 2021 Mark
German from Bloomberg said that the next
iPad Pro is going to feature both
wireless charging and reverse wireless
charging capabilities and that's
supposed to debut in 2022 which is this
guy and obviously we didn't get wireless
charging then going even further in
March of 2022 Mark German said that it's
coming with the M2 Chip which it has and
magsafe charging likely to launch in the
fall of 2022 which is when this guy
launched and if you're wondering about
Max save charging it's Max safe like on
the iPhone yes with a magnetic ring that
kind of Max safe coming to the iPad Pro
I mean Apple's already using magnets to
hold it why not just have a way where
you can have Max a charging with reverse
wireless charging capabilities and then
of course when this thing launched in
October of last year there were a lot of
rumors that were wrong well guess why
because this is not the iPad we're
supposed to get yes Max they've been
reverse wireless charging didn't come
the landscape FaceTime camera did not
come even though the iPad 10 budget
model got it newsflash the real iPad Pro
that we were supposed to get was delayed
and that is going to be the M3 iPad Pro
model in way it gets even better be
because we have even more leaks that in
fact we just got literally today as I'm
filming this we got some confirmation
about OLED so according to business
Korea Apple has ordered their OLED
panels for the 2024 models from Samsung
and LG display now this is a very old
leak all the way back in May of 2021
Apple was looking into OLED displays for
their iPads and then in March Ross young
said that OLED iPad Pros are coming in
both 11 inch and 12.9 inch sizes which
is awesome because the current 11 inch
right now still has LCD while the 12.9
inch has mini LEDs so this confirmation
for both of them is great then in July
we got even more updates saying that
there's going to be an even bigger
14-inch model that we're gonna have
under display true depth sensors coming
in the future and of course OLED but
here is the real Banger in August we got
a leak saying that Apple could adopt
hybrid OLED technology for future iPads
and the main point of that is to combine
the flexible OLED panels and make them
more rigid because the current ones are
too kind of fragile for such a large
display 11 inch to 12.9 inch the
flexible OLED can be damaged so this is
gonna fix that and giving even more
details digitimes said that the hybrid
OLED technology would allow for even
thinner iPads by making the whole panel
quite a bit thinner compared to how it
is right now with the LCD backlight and
Ross young even tweeted out a more
specific date 2024 we will see oleds on
both iPad Pro Models and Evan Rogers
asked them double stack OLED ready for
prime time spring 2024 he says yes so
about one year from now maybe a little
bit more we will get the new M3 iPad Pro
which is perfect timing with these new
OLED displays and then just a couple
months ago rashdown gave us another
update saying that the display sizes
will actually be larger 11.1 inch for
the smaller size and 13 inch OLED for
the larger size still in 2024 and then
just last month we got another leak from
Korea's ET news saying that yes these
OLED display iPad Pros are launching
next year
2024. now I know what you're gonna say
OLED sucks compared to mini LED because
it is too dim and I actually made videos
talking about that previously but check
this out we have something new in
September we had a leak saying that the
OLED iPad screen will reportedly use
twin layer tech for brighter display and
longer life so essentially instead of
having just one dim OLED layer Apple's
gonna combine two layers together to
double the brightness of the display
while not having any of the blooming
issues from mini LED it's going to be
real OLED but bright that's going to fix
all of the issues so almost a year ago
on April 7 2022 I made a tweet saying
that there's going to be a 120 hertz
dual layer OLED with high knit
brightness HDR for the iPad Pro and then
60 or 90 Hertz single layer OLED with
500 to 600 nit brightness for the iPad
Air 6 and I said that the air will
likely come first but Ross young tweeted
and said the iPad Pro is first 120 hertz
with ltpo so essentially the iPad Air
and the pros are getting OLED but the
pros get two layers for the ultimate
OLED display but wait it gets even
better because that's not all that's
coming to the M3 iPad Pro you got the
OLED display dual stack you got the Mac
safe feature the redesign that's coming
but we're also getting the M3 chip and
this one is going to be special because
it's going to come on tsmc's three
nanometer process which is launching in
the second half of 2023 later this year
on the MacBook Air so about six months
later in the spring of 2024 I expect the
M3 iPad Pro and that Chip is going to be
worth it because it's going to be super
efficient great battery life and a lot
more performance and guess what Apple
just ordered the entire tsmc three
nanometer chip supply for their a17 ship
and M3 chip so they're gonna have enough
for this guy and it doesn't stop there
because alongside the new M3 iPad Pro
with Max safe I expect that we're
getting a brand new magic keyboard case
with maxsafe built in so it's going to
attach magnetically to the iPad Pro and
then on the back of the magic keyboard
case you're going to be able to
wirelessly charge it and reverse
Wireless charge other accessories like
let's say the air pods the iPhone it's
going to be amazing and yes I already
made videos on what that's going to look
like so definitely check out this one if
you're interested so here's the main
point of the video the M2 iPad Pro is
disappointing it's a stop Gap they
skipped what we're supposed to get they
delayed it until the M3 to give us this
kind of disappointing model and honestly
I'd recommend just getting the M1 iPad
Pro instead however if you can wait then
please wait until spring of 2024 for the
M3 iPad Pro because it's gonna have Max
save charging it's gonna have the
redesign it's gonna have the dual stack
OLED displays and the killer M3 chip All
in One update it is going to be so much
better than this guy right here and I
recommend waiting so let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below and if you enjoyed this video
click the circle above subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]